With more than 350 million people suffering from depression in the world, it is undoubtedly a subject
Serious and dangerous. But what exactly is happening to a person with depression? Is there
A biological reason for those strong feelings of sadness?
In the past, depression was described as a "chemical imbalance" in the brain. And identification
Scientists believed that the cause was a decrease in the amount of neurotransmitter "serotonin" which is often called
"Happiness hormone". But the only evidence on this was that when
Some people described drugs that raise the rate of "serotonin"
This helped them ease their symptoms. Although chemical vectors have a definite role to play, however
This vision does not fully show the complexity of the disease. In recent years, scientists have begun
They note that the size and links of brain cells can play a role
Larger.
When we look at the brain of a person with depression, studies show that the hippocampus tends to be
Significantly smaller than usual. Other areas of the brain are also affected.
But this area (hippocampus) controls memory and emotions. The longer the person's suffering, the longer
Depression, the smaller the size of the hippocampus. Cells and networks are literally destroyed.
Stress has been shown to be a major cause of the decline in the number of new neurons
In this region of the brain. Studies have shown that when this region of the brain is renewed
New neurons are stimulated, mood improves. Interestingly, many drugs
Modern ones, including those that affect serotonin rate, have an indirect effect on large size
Brain cells. This probably explains why serotonin-containing drugs help some patients - but for reasons
Different from what we thought. It also stimulates the release of other chemical vectors
It stimulates the formation and growth of new neurons, and by knowing this some
Scientists now believe that the focus should be on drugs that directly affect the formation of new neurons.
Although neurons and hormones are the main influencing factors, many have been discovered
Genetic factors also. One research confirms that there is variation in the gene
Responsible for the transmission of serotonin makes the individual more susceptible to depression. Each individual has two copies of
This gene - one from the father and the other from the mother. They can be either short or long
After tracking 800 young adults for more than 5 years. Studies have shown that 33% of individuals
Those with one short version of the gene have been depressed after stressful life events - and people who have
Two short copies of the gene were worse off. On the other hand, people with two long copies of the gene were
Are less likely to have depression with similar stress in life. Many have been selected
Other genes that increase the likelihood of depression. This is logical when
Keep in mind that depression and bipolar disorder occur in families. Studies have shown on
Twins that if one of them suffer from bipolar disorder, the other face the possibility of infection
By 60-80%
Therefore, although the real cause or symptoms of depression have not been fully identified - they have believed that
There is a huge list of other variables that studies suggest they play a role in this -
It is necessary to remember that depression is a disease with a biological basis, in addition to
Psychological and social effects. It is not simply a vulnerability that a person must
"Beyond" or even something we can control, such as heart disease or cancer
The highlight of this topic is of paramount importance, in order to obtain
On funding and appropriate research.
But is depression just a human phenomenon? We discussed the question: "Do dogs get depressed?"
In another video from AsapTHOUGHT, we discovered several studies conducted to understand depression
Among other types, including domestic pets. You can click the link in the details box
To access that video.
You can also read the book "Mad Animals" by "Laura Bretman" which deals with
This topic - in fact, you can get it for free from our friends at "Audible" by going to
audible.com/asap. This site is the main provider of audio books with more than one hundred and fifty thousand books
Of all kinds of literature. You can download this audio book or any other book of your choice
Free at audible.com/asap and for subscription you get one free book
Per month. Special thanks to Audible for helping them make these videos possible!
If you think you are suffering from depression, we have entered some sources and other information
In the details box.
They followed us to more scientific videos every week!